[موسيقى] أكثر
ما أحبه في كونك طاهياً
هو أنه
يمكنك السماح لعصائرك الإبداعية بالتدفق ،
يمكنك
طهي ما تشعر به مثل الطهي ، يمكنك
تخيل الطعام
في ذهنك ثم وضعه على
طبق وفي النهاية عندما تقدمه
لضيفك
ترى تلك الابتسامة الكبيرة التي
تجعل الشيف سعيدًا ،
أنا صبور جدًا ، لقد افتتحت أول
مطعم لي هنا في دبي عام 2005.
من المهم جدًا أن تكون الثقافة المحلية
جزءًا لا يتجزأ من
مطبخنا هنا
في رمضان ، لقد صنعنا طبقًا خاصًا  الحلوى في
الهند ، وهي عبارة عن
تورتة من حليب الإبل ،
نعم صباح الخير ، هذه هي الدورة الأولى ،
إنها وجبة ذواقة اليوم
لتأتي إلى هنا في مكان مثل مزرعة وتلتقي
بالإبل من حولك ولتتمكن من إطعامها
كما تعلم  هناك نوع من العظم
أو الاتصال لديك لأن هذا
الاتصال
أقوم به وأعطيه لضيفي وهذا كله من
خلال الطعام إنه حب للطعام
وهذا هو المكان الذي يحدث فيه كل شيء هنا
يتم إحضار الجمال هنا.  إعادة اصطف
لقد تم القيام بكل عمليات الحلب
[تصفيق
] أعني أن الجمال جزء لا يتجزأ
من الشرق الأوسط ودبي
وهي تنقل الناس حول الصحراء
ولكن أيضًا ينسى الناس أن هذه هي في
الواقع
ماشية تطعم البشر ،
أعني هذه المزرعة هم  ما يقرب من تسعة
آلاف
رأس من الماشية وتنتج حوالي 5000 لتر من
حليب الإبل كل يوم
، من الرائع أن يكون لديك منتج مثل هذا هنا في دبي والذي يمكنك بعد ذلك استخدامه وإعداد بعض الأطباق الرائعة
[الموسيقى]
لذلك لدينا حليب الإبل  احصل على
الطهي ،
دعنا نذوب الشوكولاتة
ثم نسكب
حليب الإبل لدينا ، انظر إلى تلك
النظرة إلى اللمعان الذي أشعر به شخصيًا أن
حليب الإبل أكثر صحة
وله نكهات خفية جدًا
خاصة به وهو
هلام جيدًا مع  الحلويات الهندية لذا
فهي
تكريمنا الصغير لرمضان sahavia استمتع بالمساء ومن جانبي
كاري رمضان شكرا لك